too many households in this country I've
often stood here and criticized the
conservative government on its energy
price hike
inflation interest rates the situation
that faces our young people throughout
the United Kingdom where too many of
them live with the fear that they will
never be able to own the house of their
own that they would like or that the
ever increasing rent rates in this
country in my city in Edinburgh is out
Regis put too many options beyond the
reach
and then there's the fact that the
chancellor didn't listen when the
liberal Democrats asked them to cut
energy bills by 500 pounds per household
which would have made a significant
difference to so many families or the
fact that the growth in the economy in
the first three months of this year was
only 0.1 percent that according to the
ons after tackling taking inflation into
account the average pay fell by three
percent or that the take-home salary
fell by more than 1400 pounds
speaker I beg your partner I was
delighted when I saw this this motion
because our economy in the United
Kingdom is on its knees
and so are far too many families and not
just in Scotland
but my disappointment comes from the
fight
that the members in front of me do not
seem to appreciate
that they are in a unique position
a unique position of which I and I'm
sure many other members are very jealous
that they are actually as a party in a
position to do something about it in
Scotland and by that I don't mean
Independence which it turns out this
debate is actually about after all
and Scotland in a second in Scotland in
Edinburgh West I hear every week from my
constituents business people who managed
to make it through the pandemic who are
struggling with energy costs
and with the burden that the Scottish
government could alleviate business
taxis
but they choose not to certainly
I Thank The Honorable member for giving
way and I wonder if she would associate
herself with the comments made by the
Scottish leader of the liberal Democrats
that Scotland is an ancient nation and
should and would never exist again
thank you very much I Thank The
Honorable lady for her Petty and
irrelevant
by taking a comment made and taking it
out of context when we are speaking
about the lives and livelihood of people
in this country you cannot afford to
feed their children we have to have a
petty debate about a comment made in
February which has been taken out of
context I thought the honorable lady's
contributions were normally better than
that to return to the issue at hand and
the problems facing Earth constituents
surely the course Yes actually Madam
Deputy speaker The Honorable lady has
made me quite angry because this is far
more important than that
surely surely the cost of living for so
many people in Scotland
so many people are working our
constituents could be alleviated
if we did not now pay more tax than
anywhere else in the United Kingdom it
is so bad that the Scottish no thank you
it is so bad that Scottish newspapers
today are reporting that the SMP green
government is concerned that the
taxation burden if it increases any mean
no encourage people to move elsewhere is
that not Dreadful yes certainly I'm very
grateful to the to the honorable lady
and I think when she speaks about the
financial pressures and burdens that are
on families and communities she's
actually she's she's hitting the nail
right on the head her Edinburgh West
constituents how important to them do
she think it is when they don't have to
worry about the cost of a prescription
rather than find 9.65 they can be
certain that their children if they make
their grades will get to University
without fear of funding or any other
benefit that they enjoy in Scotland but
not in England how grateful are her
constituents thank you very much
actually when my constituents come
what they can playing about it's not
that they might
um have to pay that amount for
prescriptions if they're not for the
Scottish government what they complain
about is the burden that they face every
day at the moment what businesses
complain to me about is the Scottish
government and what constituents
regularly complain to me about is that
they don't understand why this Scottish
government is not doing something about
the state of our NHS it's not doing
something to provide a better education
for the children to give them a better
chance in life that's what my
constituents in a moment
and ask for brexit well actually I agree
with the Scottish national party it is
doing immense damage
to our economy it's making life
incredibly difficult for businesses
and it's increasing the burden on
families
but what surprises me about that is that
it fails to recognize
that you want to take Scotland out of
the United Kingdom
would be to repeat and to amplify that
damage to Scotland's economy to
Scotland's income and to Scotland's
households so why is it that the
Scottish national party wants to inflict
the same damage again of course
Independence is their solution
it's the solution to everything not at
the moment thank you
and I have to say
I have to see that when The Honorable
member for Paisley and refuge of South
was talking about bad governments making
bad decisions I had to bow to her
expertise as a member of the SMP because
when it comes to bad governments making
bad decisions they are in class of their
own at the moment one only has to look
at the mounting bill for the ferries at
the the burden of business rates as I've
already mentioned as at the state of our
NHS at this state of our education
yes certainly The Honorable lady keeps
referring to the NHS and education you
actually require Public Funding to
support those and much as it's very
common in here to talk about failing on
health and failing on education while
all four health services are struggling
after the pandemic it is still the case
that both early waiting times and cancer
awaiting times in Scotland are
significantly better than the other
three and in closing the attainment gap
which does help young people of a better
future both at hires and positive
destinations that Gap has closed by
two-thirds while the SMP have been in
power so this nonsense that somehow The
Honorable lady expects things public
services to be better but with less
taxation is the same reality check
needed as the benches opposite
[Applause]
thank you very much Madam Jeopardy
speaker I Thank The Honorable lady for
intervention because like this the rest
of the SMP she does talk a very good
game but very often forget that those of
us in these benches live in Scotland
have constituency surgeries in Scotland
and we know the reality of the cures of
people every week complaining about the
Public Services in Scotland which I know
the SMP blame Westminster for but they
always Overlook the fact that the
Scottish government has had record
amounts of money now I do not for one
moment believe that the economic
stewardship of the United Kingdom at the
moment is the best stewardship it could
have it falls far short as I have
already mentioned but
I think it is Rich coming from the SMP
not to recognize the mistakes that they
have made
I do not believe there is anyone in this
house in any party who is not concerned
about the cost of living front crisis
inflation or the energy prices though we
are all facing at the moment where we
differ is in our solution to it now The
Honorable member for Paisley and
renfordshire South offered us the I
Words which I'm not surprised came up in
this debate I suspected it might be what
it was about all along she offered us
that well I would offer three
alternative I words
incompetence
inability and ineffectiveness a little
bit Integrity all of them
I believe the voters in Scotland will
take into account the next time they go
to The Ballot Box on a general election
and they will apply them to both
governments and their stewardship of
their economic well-being
and I think at that point we will see
change because the people of Scotland
have had enough
and they want a government two
governments who are competent
able and effective
Marion fellows
thank you madam Deputy speaker Madam
Deputy speaker the cost of living crisis
affects disabled people far more than it
does the general population and I make
no bones about repeating not entirely
but parts of the speech I made this
morning in Westminster hall because I
think it Bears repetition
briefings from a variety of disabled
organizations telling me that this
government has continuously failed
disabled people their Terrors and their
families that it's tinkering around the
edges
of a cost of living crisis which is
affecting millions of people across the
UK and that the impact of this crisis
affects those with disabilities their
Terrors and their families even more
seriously
this morning out on my iPad and the
first story I read in the news
was the story of a man
dealing formula milk for his baby
because his wife and he could no longer
continue to dilute the formula they gave
to their baby
I wish this was an isolated incident but
as many here today were no doubt testify
this is not just a feckless couple who
are doing it all wrong this is real life
in the UK today
and it's even worse for those disabled
households yeah yeah scope it's recent
disability price tag report showed the
cost of being disabled in 2023 has risen
to
975 pounds per month
but a disabled household this figure is
inclusive of disability benefits such as
pip which were designed to offset the
additional costs associated with being
disabled this figure is 300 pounds per
month upon entries on 2016-17 figures
when the additional costs were 6.75 but
scoped has recently warned that the
fitter could increase to
1122 pounds per month
if the figure is updated to accommodate
the inflationary course for the period
2022 23.
the bottom line is that this
government's support for those with
disabilities has been wholly inadequate
throughout the cost of living crisis in
disability rights UK have said the cost
of living payments that this government
have given don't touch this side exactly
what's happening I'm grateful to your
forgiving way we saw in both 2012 and
2016 the two welfare acts that really
changed Social Security across the UK
does she agree with me that one of the
big failures was to do cumulative impact
assessments what has been the impact on
a disabled woman who's a lone parent
with three children literally being hit
by changes to disability benefit the
two-child cap two child limit the
benefit cap and the benefit freeze thank
you I thank my honorable friend for that
intervention she's absolutely right
this government does not take into
account real lived experience and people
with multiple differences in being a
woman being disabled being a single
parent it just isn't good enough
disabled people Madam Deputy speaker
often face higher course for the gas and
electricity many disabled people say
they need more heating to stay warm and
I think most of us here could recognize
that and others say they have to use
extra electricity to charge up items of
assistive technology
my parliamentary assistant went to a
drop-in session and came back to my
office almost in tears when he spoke to
the parent of a child who requires three
separate machines to keep them alive
overnight
and she could not afford to pay for the
electric electricity costs for a band
150 pounds extra even including the the
cap that the government has tried to put
on electricity crisis doesn't help
disabled people have been suffering from
years and if you give someone a
percentage on a very small amount it's
still a very small increase and
according to professional association
for social work and social workers seven
million people almost half of those
living in poverty in the UK are either
disabled or live with someone with a
disability Russell trust says that about
half of the people using food banks are
disabled
I sometimes wonder and I know that this
government does meet some effort and I
congratulate the disabilities Minister
who I spoke to this morning but they do
not get the bigger picture so that when
something like this cost of living
prizes rears its ugly head what it does
is it plows the most vulnerable in our
society and to further debt and into
further difficulty
that I haven't even mentioned yet enough
very briefly see that anyone with
foodology or anyone who requires special
food is an even worse case during this
cost of living living crisis now
my party has consistently called Oneness
government to uplift Universal Credit
increase it to 25 pounds per week and
extend it to all means-tested Legacy
benefits those people who went through
the covid-19
pandemic and got no additional cost
this is just not right we need to look
at this this government needs to do its
job properly and actually help people
well
Madam Deputy speaker
in Scotland the Scottish government is
trying
to make things better our adult
disability payment the child payment
which has recently been doubled and will
hopefully be increased even more all
goal to help families and disabled
people
much more than is happening in the rest
of the UK but there is a cost as my
honorable friend from Angus has already
said there is a cost to this and that
cost us yes like me pay more tax to
pay for it
I have yet to meet your constituent who
tells me I object to paying more tax to
help folks less well-off than myself
and maybe just be that motherwell and
worship it's a beacon of light I don't
think so motherwell and we're sure
constitutions is built an old mining
communities to coast and still
communities and they'll tend to know
what it's like to be in poverty but they
also know that helping each other is the
sign of a civilization
Madam Deputy speaker
the latest white paper from this
government into the health and
disability white paper actually raises
the Specter of putting more disabled
people into the likelihood that they
might face sanctions
can we really believe this in the 21st
century that we're going to such and
disabled people
because they will have to move on to
Universal Credit and then they won't get
not only will they not get what they're
entitled to any interest is will be also
barred under that punitive regime this
government also is very bad at sign
posting yeah and I'll say for an example
of that pension Ted it's the uptake of
which has been totally totally
disgraceful Madam Deputy speaker I'm
watching my time very carefully and I
will just very briefly reflect on what
the Prime Minister was doing today for
the farm to Fort Summit AT number 10
where um it seems to me a lamentable
effort to try and mitigate the disaster
that has been brexit on our economy and
on the food supply chain
this government was warned
warmed often during the brexit debates
many of which I myself was able to
attend it is not good enough to we need
Scotland needs and warrants to go back
into the EU
many people in Scotland still believe
that that is the best way forward for
this country and we also want to follow
the examples of countries like France
where they put blocks on prices to keep
things cheaper during a cost of living
crisis Madame Deputy speaker
country is in a terrible state
Scotland is in a terrible state in terms
of people who are suffering when the
cost of living I beg your pardon sir I
didn't look up and see that you had
changed places Madam Deputy speaker
um
it's almost inconceivable
that both the lib Dems and the labor
party are batting a heart Tory brexit
they don't want to see how awful it has
been for people right across the UK what
it's done in terms of food prices what
it's done well I'm just about to finish
my I'm sorry no as my time is up my time
is actually incorrect okay
I'll leave it to the honorability to
correct me later when she finds time but
can I just say that it is really
important
that this Society this government
reflects
that Society is judged on how it treats
its most vulnerable people and on that
measure this government this feeling
yeah Paul Williams
yes Deputy speaker and I will attempt to
be brief so that my colleagues even SMP
can can take past
um I before I guess to my only marks I
just want to note that this is emotional
albeit derived from the s p this is a
motion about the cost of living crisis
before the UK Parliament
and I think the empty bench is with one
honorable exception I'm looking forward
to listening to the empty benches will
be noted in Wales and will be noted in
England they have no interest they have
only consents
Mr Deputy speaker the latest snapshots
of poverty in Wales published by the
Bevin Foundation found that more than
one in A1 Welsh households either
sometimes often or always
do not have enough for the basics
the latest round three Foundation
figures show that 36 percent of children
in my own arvonne constituency live in
poverty that's it hardly varies across
the constituencies in Wales and even the
generally better off veil of glomorgan
constituency has the child poverty rate
of 28 we should be ashamed that people
are being forced to make impossible
choices between Essentials and that they
have no option but to turn to Charities
and food banks for the very basics of
existence
food price inflation much higher than
the general rates is behind much of the
suffering that we have seen over the
past couple of years and we know of
course as has already been sent that's
uh this hits the poorest hardest that is
one reason why Pride supports his motion
and in particular the call for an
unofficial investigation into the
soaring Supermarket prices unsuspected
profiteering
so in this wind-up can the minister uh
in the plan you tell us what steps the
UK governments are taking to make sure
that as wholesale prices fall the
savings that immediately passed on to
customers
that is a genuine concern that's a
failure to do so will mean that the
current extortionist prices and in some
cases immoral levels of for searing I
suspect will become entrenched in the
economy into the future
energy bills remains Sky High despite
some government's help and that's in
great contrast to neighboring countries
mainly in the European Union many
members will like me have received
heartbreaking correspondence
this last winter from people struggling
uh with cold and damp houses because
they cancel false the Heats
given that energy bills are expected to
increase by 17 this year alone and as
households who have had seems of savings
or take out stats in order to cope with
high prices and now less financially
resilience I fear that this coming
winter will be even more difficult
exactly but there is time between now
and the winter for the UK governments to
put supports measures in place and
they'll list four of them firstly a fair
tax on share buying backs including the
3.8 billion worth announced by shell
last month that could be used to
increase supports provided under the
energy price guarantee
secondly the energy bills support scheme
could be redesigned to Target
financially vulnerable households
uh another round of alternative fuel
payments could be guaranteed sets at a
level which better reflects the increase
in the cost of alternative fuels
experience being off good households
something that has been neglected in the
past and particularly Mr Deputy speaker
the concern of mine that we need the
fairer system of emergency help for poor
people when the weather is particularly
old for families for children for people
with a disability they have a better
system in Scotland though it appears
that this Parliament isn't interested
but too many of my constituents on a
plunder areas miss out by being on the
wrong side of an oceanal weather line
drawn up or for bureaucratic convenience
now looking Beyond next winter our
system
must be redesigned so that's energy is
Affordable to all one option would be to
introduce a social tariff that provides
the safety net for vulnerable customers
one group of people for whom such a
safety nets would be particularly
important is people with disabilities
the higher cost of specialist equipment
equipment higher usage of everyday
essentials and energy and an inadequate
welfare system are all making it harder
for disabled households to meet the
extra costs of that disability
on average and accounting for inflation
over the 22-23 period figures by scope
show that households with at least one
disabled adult or child need an
additional
1122 pounds a month to have the same
standard of living as those without
proposed the UK government's reform has
outlined in the health and disability
white paper that's making the situation
worse by using the deeply flawed
personal Independence payments
assessment process to determine
eligibility for financial supports for
those not well enough to work I call on
the governments to rethink this matter
this is particularly concerning in Wales
as we have the highest level of poverty
and proportion of disabled people of any
other nation in the UK
now since Scotland gained certain powers
over disability benefits they have been
able to chance a different course by
committing to reducing owner's
assessments for people with disabilities
removing the private sector from the
decision-making process and moving
towards a personal centered approach
which truly listens to people's needs
when they are disabled it is high time
that Wales and England for that matter
should have the same Powers as Scotland
so that we can all begin to restore the
dignity and respect the treatments with
disabilities deserve
now before I close I would like to touch
upon supports for small and medium
businesses small and medium businesses
out of the heart of the Welsh economy
employing
62.6 of Welsh workers
ensuring that they are supported through
the current crisis is therefore vital
now despite this they received no
additional supports with their energy
bills from the chancellor during the
Spring budgets
24 of small businesses are trapped in
fixed energy constructs which were
agreed when prices were up the highest
the Federation of small businesses
estimate that this issue is affecting up
to 17 500 small businesses in Wales
many are concerned that this may force
them to downsize to restructure and even
to close
putting at disks the jobs and
communities that they support So finally
asked the minister Willy commit the UK
government taking real action and they
require that energy companies provide
opportunities for businesses to
renegotiate the contracts to reflect
current rates
Gavin Newlands thank you very much Mr
Deputy speaker
um many of my constitutions like many
across the country are struggling
struggling to pay their energy bills
struggling to put food in the table
struggling to keep their head above the
financial flood waters that threaten
them and their families energy bills up
300 or so in the last two years food
prices up 17 in the latest Rich survey
which some of the the cheapest and most
essential Foods soaring the most
mortgages up by 61 just this last year
this of course caused by the disastrous
seven week reign of the previous prime
minister and her Chancellor but if the
frequent excuses we've had today again
trusted out with a bench is opposite for
their inflation attack on all this but
hitting the lowest paid as Ukraine the
problem with that argument is that it
shows just how short-sighted and
backward thinking UK energy and economic
policy has been for decades now I am no
geopolitical expert but it seems to me
that by pegging your electricity prices
to the wholesale cost of gas and leaving
so many of our eggs in a basket
controlled by Putin and Madras oligarchs
are relying on a region that has never
been in renowned for stability it was
nonsense on Stouts instead of using past
decades to invest in our energy sector
build a green industrial base and begin
with the process of decarbonizing our
grid and therefore reducing our
dependence on the likes of Putin the
labor government so the past pushed away
behind the dash for gas well authorities
paid lip service to the very idea of
industrial strategy but it's their
economic strategy exemplified by the
previous prime minister and those
catastrophic seven weeks that's caused
mortgage rates to Skyrocket that's left
our economy in a mile in wrecked
wrecking any ability to recover from the
kind of shocks to the system we've seen
over recent years whether from covered
or from Putin's warmongering and most of
all it's a Kamikaze brexit Unleashed in
our society has destroyed what was left
of the UK's capacity to invest in its
own recovery and its own future this
Deputy speaker in 2016 my constituency
voted two to one to remain in the EU
making station is new and know that our
economic prosperity and our wider
Society are inextricable linked to our
European allies from the airport which
delivers the largest cargo exports by
value in Scotland to the whiskey bonds
and warehouses which sleep the thrusts
of millions of Europeans through to the
universities and colleges with links to
their contemporaries on the continent
and the holy is based in my constituency
who experienced firsthand every day the
kafka-esque World created by the current
government they have all been hit hard
by brexit and so have their staff they
and we have lost a huge amount since
brexit but then so has the labor party
many of us can remember the Savage
criticism the member for Israel from
North received from his own benches
because he in their view was a secret
brexiteer now everyone in the new model
labor party is a brexiteria including
the current branch office manager
elected after the previous
democratically elected leader was booted
from office by the big boss here
uh it's too surprised that they are
getting very excited about the small
increase in the opinion polls in
Scotland because let's face it what else
do they really have to get excited about
Mr deficit speaker the boss down here
has declared he doesn't care it doesn't
care if he sounds like a conservative
well the shadow foreign secretary tells
his radio listeners the labor party
can't be picking through all the
conservative legislative legislation and
appealing it if it ever got back into
office he promised the abolition of
tuition fees for higher education
abandoned in England but maintained by a
Scottish government trying to ensure
that education and learning isn't the
The Preserve of our welfare the leader
of the opposition promised Community
ownership of the male energy and water
abandoned England but maintained in
Scotland where it has jurisdiction with
water bills in Scotland being
substantial and lower and 35 percent
more per capita invested in
infrastructure and he also resigned from
the labor front bench after what he said
was a catastrophic result in the brexit
referendum but he's now happier for the
UK
Scottish government plans for a future
within Europe and alongside our friends
and allies because the truth is
sad truth is that you couldn't put a
flag paper between the two front benches
in this place they are both set in
policies that will exacerbate and extend
the cost of living crisis both hell-bent
and ignoring reality and pluring on with
the explosion from a single Market both
sticking their head in the sand as to
the damage that Ultra free market
economic policies are costing and will
continue to cost ordinary households
across these aisles regardless of who
sits on the treasury benches I wish the
recently selected labor candidate in
prison Hampshire North all the best at
the next election because she will need
it going round the doors with her toy
Manifesto colored in red and I read how
it sells granny for a few hundred votes
in the Midlands module and then that
I'll give away
The Honorable gentleman for giving away
does he agree with his colleague from
Glasgow South who said that labor are
just the same as the toys is not a
strategy it's the absence of a strategy
and telling people labor and
conservatives are the same won't get us
very far did you agree with your
colleague
I'm very grateful gentle affiliation
intervention who said it was our
strategy it's a fact
all I'm doing is going to do in fact if
he wants me to read out his legal
speeches I've gone back on his word in
terms of nationalizing various injuries
I'm more than happy to do that but I'm
not sure if we've got time for it but
everyone here and everyone in Scotland
knows that his Manifesto will Victoria
right in its direction and it might work
in Edinburgh South but it's not going to
work in many places across the central
belt of Scotland yeah yeah
they see the delicious irony that the
Electoral fortunes of Scottish labor are
hinged entirely on the Electoral
Ambitions of middle England
it's as if he's read my speech enough
sitting beside him so maybe a different
speech because I've made the making the
very same point indeed I just made the
same point about Midlands marginal is
the labeling is betting the entire
future
um of the UK and winning a few votes in
English marginals
um and Scottish labor A Better Way
Captain reality that's not going to cut
it when you're out campaigning the doors
in the next election
um
at the same time at the same time the
labor candidate and pays on him for
North will be campaigning against a
Scottish government that has rolled out
1 104 Euros a year of free high quality
Child Care delivered over a quarter
million baby boxes to new parents scrap
prescription charges extended free bus
travel to under-22s maintained free eye
tests free skill meals for peoples on
primary one to five all measures that
are putting money back in their pocket
so the people where it's need need most
and their rejection and utter rejection
of a fallacy that the state should be
rolled back a fantasy that's Afflicted
the UK for the last 13 years for the
labor party to turn their backs on
reversing the lunacy of the previous 13
years is a complete abdication of
responsibility responsibility that
should be focused on those who need the
state's help the most for just one
example the first steps interesting
trust report this month on the impact of
the cost of living crisis on child diets
found that infinite formals had
increased by an average of 24 well the
cheapest formula went up by 45 they have
standard formula now costs just over 14
pounds well the Healthy Start Grant in
England Wales in Northern Ireland was
frozen this year in less than two-thirds
of eligible families are successful in
applying for the grant at the same time
the Scottish government has uprighted
our best art package by over 10 this
year and has hit 80 an 88 uptake rate as
well as rolling out and expanding the
Scottish Chow payment getting to support
the households who desperately it's
shameful it's a shameful that we have
babies in this country with parents who
cannot afford to feed them even the
basics infants are trying with Hunger
because the patents the UK government
has decided it is enough to feed them
doesn't cut it in the real world and
once those infants Deputy speaker the
chances I'm getting a healthy diet have
decreased with fresh food inflation
since 17 this is where the shops are
this is for shops of fruit and veg at
all there will be those opposite of the
gold details empty fridge shelves and
rocketing prices of imported produce or
nothing to do with brexit and all
someone else's fault the holidays they
Farmers the shops the workers the
parents the children anything to avoid
responsibility of the catastrophic mess
they have created they wanted to take
back control instead they've taken us
back to the 1970s with inflation through
Earth industrial action across the
economy living standards falling
continually and food shortages in our
shops just this week the zimmers and
zealots who pushed the brexit campaign
in phosphorus are gathered for a
festival of delusion up the road from
this place the influence the influence
of these cranks and charlatans have had
on their body politic and the direction
of these Isles is surely the most
revealing piece of evidence that the UK
is a bursted flush they have succeeded
in isolating us from our allies and
continuing the harmful economic policies
they're a great leader Thatcher imposed
in the past those who promised that
brexit had been taking back controls to
explain exactly what control they think
they've taken back as a control over an
energy Market that is rigged against
consumers and for the profits and that
profits the middlemen as a control of
the tens of thousands of skilled workers
who have fled this country in recent
years to the former homes in the EU
countries so Disturbed so dispirited
were they by the hostile environment and
bureaucratic nonsense cooked up by the
benches opposite with the connivans now
the connivance of the lower benches too
leaving our Health Service without
skilled and dedicated staff when we need
it most and virtually every bus company
in the country canceling Services
because so many drivers have moved to
Poland as a control over an economy that
even the government's own office for
Budget responsibility says we'll end up
four percent smaller than it would have
been without brexit we're from
productivity which will never come back
while the UK sits in unsplended
isolation this is an economic crisis
which is not going to go away it is
permanently embedded in the fundamental
structure of how the UK operates
anywhere in which the UK governing class
and both parties have thundered back on
the rest of Europe and what is equal a
shame for is it with a labor party
that's fully signed up to that brexit
agenda and signed up to policies which
was continue to take us down that field
road at least Scotland has oh yeah at
least Scotland has a government that is
taking action despite the fiscal
restrictions imposed by the UK to tackle
child poverty so it's got a child
payment and best start to create a
social security system that puts dignity
and respect at its heart to invest in
decarborisation and adjust transition to
Net Zero and at least Scotland has a
party that takes its responsibility to
its citizens to do better seriously you
know Scotland is a government that wants
to rejoin the world and be part of the
mainstream of Europe around setting
self-imposed Exile and Mr Deputy speaker
at least Scotland has a government that
wants us to fully harness their wealth
and resources of our country natural and
human as an independent Sovereign Nation
it's time those on both sides of the
front benches out of their way of that
Democratic mandate and all the people of
Scotland the chance to escape a union
that's costing them more than ever
yeah
yeah Claudia Webb
thank you Mr speaker the cost of living
crisis is not really a cost of living
crisis in reality it's a cost of greed
crisis it's greed inflation driven by a
lack of political interest in protecting
Ordinary People and of course as with
any crisis it's the most vulnerable in
our society who suffer most and there
are few more vulnerable and more
unsupported in our society than those
with a disability disabled people are of
course no strangers to poverty and
crisis under 13 years of Tory government
they have faced constant cuts and
conscious cruelty at every term
sharpened by punitive and pointless
assessment regimes conditionality and
sanctions we live under a go under a
government
that responded to the UK's Mass crisis
of death and hunger by suggesting
suggesting people should work more
should work more hours or take a second
job to help their help with their
finances but many disabled people face
huge challenges to work a single job let
alone a second and are even harder hit
by Soaring costs of energy Fuel and
other Essentials
as The Honorable member for mother world
and we show has highlighted
according to research by disability
charity scope disabled households in the
poorest fifth percentile spent twice as
much of the household budget on energy
bills are twice as likely to have a
courthouse and are three times more
likely to be unable to afford food
the Heat or eat scandal
is a mark of disgrace on this country
not least because people can afford to
do either but disabled people suffer the
worst of it and it shames us as a nation
again and again for well over a decade
now the heaviest burden is placed on the
shoulders of those least able to pay
while they're while the wealth of the
rich piles up
and in the constituency like mine in
Leicester East where we suffer some of
the worst health and lowest incomes in
the country the evils of our unequal
system hit especially hard
in my constituency
far more children 37 compared to 26
nationally live in a family with at
least one disabled member than those
with none
piling yet more hunger ill health stigma
and misery on children in a country that
is already failing them
the median annual wage for workers in
Leicester East
is 19
960 pounds compared to an average of 25
837 in the East Midlands
and an average of 27
756 in the rest of the UK
the level of poverty in my constituency
is Stark my community is hurting the
level of suffering is deep I am
witnessing this daily it's painful
yet the conservatives continue to offer
at best a sticking plaster for the
Grievous wounds they inflict on the poor
and vulnerable
in 2017 the United Nations has condemned
the UK's government treatment of
disabled people as a human catastrophe
and it has only grown worse since then
this abuse and abandonment abandonment
of our disabled people is an
international disgrace
it's a stain on the UK standing amongst
Nations
until this cruelty toward disabled
people and all our millions of poor and
vulnerable citizens is reverse the UK
cannot consider itself a Civilized
Nation
an everyday's delay is putting it in
putting it right means more lives lost
and ruined
the government needs to tackle prices
and address the inequality of extra
costs that disabled people face work
towards the redistribution of wealth
and establish a welfare system that
provides an adequate level of support
for disabled people
Miss Deputy speaker
we need radical transformational change
thank you
and the wind ups will begin immediately
after Mr Henry said star
no Drew Henry
I thought you would give me an
instruction to sit down there as a
deputy speaker thank you for allowing me
to speak in what is a cost of living
debate now the shadow Secretary of State
and I share an Allegiant star football
team and when we go to some some of the
stadiums particularly the big events we
can often look across and see the empty
seats across and go did the opposition
come dress the seats and I look here
behind them and wonder if the rest of
his party have done the same but no no
they haven't bothered to turn up because
as The Honorable member for Leicester
East has just pointed out this is an
issue about whether about not people can
afford the Heat their homes or eat in
fact it's worse than that because in
Scotland during the winter we had people
who couldn't afford the Heat or eat in
their homes and this is an important
thing that we should have seen the labor
party turn out for but of course we
didn't and when it comes to brexit well
that harms we've heard quite a lot of
the harms today in this chamber Mr
Deputy speaker and my colleagues have
covered a number of them from the
economy from trade to the impact on our
population to education to rights and
Devolution the cost of living and the
cost of food and as my honorable friend
for Edinburgh North and leaf pointed out
when food price inflation goes up it
disproportionately hurts the least
advantaged in our society and the
poorests that are there but it's worse
than that because food pricing inflation
on Basic Foods is actually higher than
the headline rate it goes up even more
these are the basic Staples that people
rely on and yet the labor party couldn't
even bother to turn up to discuss that
here today with us in this debate now
the brexit
the the brexit that's been forced upon
us is the gift that Scotland didn't want
and keeps on giving misery it keeps on
delivering misery across Scotland for
people I've just mentioned some of the
things that affect it and of course
labor now support brexit in fact as we
heard from the leader the Libra leader
if that sounds conservative they just
don't care about that it's made sure
that GDP has four percent lower across
the UK
870 pounds per year increased on average
in a cost of living and by the end of
last year brexit had already cost nearly
6 billion pounds across the UK in higher
food bills according to the London
School of economics
100 billion pounds in Lost economic
input and the Brit when it comes to
business the British Chamber of Commerce
have said more than half of their
members have faced difficulties because
of brexit and they quote one of the
members saying that leaving the EU has
made us uncompetitive as a fairly
standard comment that they get to them
the cost in human capital uh Mr Deputy
speaker has been tremendous for us we've
six to nine percent of Care Home staff
in Scotland used to be EU Nationals
before brexit and now we see that we're
struggling to find those spaces for
people in Care Homes because we can't
get the staff and the UK government are
doing nothing nothing about getting that
sorted out they're doing nothing to
solve the misery for people that need
that kind of support and of course we we
have unemployment rate a record low in
Scotland at three percent so where are
we supposed to get the people that the
brexit has starved us of the human
capital that we need and of course we
heard the I word I thought the honorable
member from the uh from Edinburgh
um West was going to talk about Ireland
independent Ireland with a over the next
two years at 27 billion Euro Surplus for
it so but no no she didn't want to do
that she doesn't want to talk about the
success stories of those small
independent countries with less
resources than Scotland they've actually
stayed in the European Union and grown
as a benefit of it and when we talk
about energy Mr Deputy speaker I just
want to reflect on a letter or an issue
I'd raise I should say with a Secretary
of State for energy about the higher
energy tariffs that we face in the
highlands and islands of Scotland I got
uh an answer back because you know I
said we need to do something about this
a weight offered to work with them to
see what we could do about this but no
the answer I got back and headquarters
Geographic circumstances are the issue
the distances involved results in higher
costs the dispute distribute there than
other places in Britain well that's rich
as we export as we export our renewable
energy around the UK it doesn't matter
when the advantage is being taken of
that where the distances are does it it
doesn't matter it only matters when it
costs us more in Scotland and they're
not willing to do anything about it
that's the similar thing about off gas
grid regulation for people who are
struggling in rural communities with the
off gas grid situation because they pay
a much higher uh premium for their
energy than anywhere else they'll
probably have to use more electricity at
a higher rate than Maine's gas and of
course higher costs for liquid
petroleum gas and of course for heating
oil as well Mr Deputy speaker but of
course the answer I got back was uh no
they they're they're the array is to
protect suppliers before people that's
the response I got from the UK
government it's simply not good enough
from this UK government to just wash
their hands of the situation where
people are struggling particularly in
rural communities with exorbitant costs
to heat their homes during the the
winter and when it comes to credit
balances I'm grateful for my honorable
friend for mentioning the campaign I've
got a credit balance is this Mr Deputy
speaker is where people are struggling
but electricity companies hold on to
their money in credit sometimes in the
case of one pensioner to my constituency
nearly 2 000 pounds in credit and
looking to increase our direct debit
increase our direct debit even though
she had two thousand pounds with them
supposedly in the bank with them for
safe keeping for use for whatever they
want to do it that money should be
returned to people but no that's not
that's not going to be done either what
we get back is customers can ask for
that money back well of course some
people are too frightened to look at
their bills because of the costs that
they get that they're facing just now
some people don't know some people are
actually intimidated some people are
actually told they can get that money
back by their electricity companies or
they can get a portion of it back or
whatever these are the rights of people
that should be fulfilled they should be
able to get their money automatically
returned not kept on credit balances for
companies so they can use it for their
own ends they that's exasperated
exacerbating poverty for people uh there
and and when we talk about um and I'm
grateful to The Honorable member for
Edinburgh West for bringing up uh the uh
the business rates because as we've
heard with a small business bonus we
have a hundred thousand businesses in
Scotland that pay no rate whatsoever so
when it comes to helping uh people in
Scotland when it comes to helping small
business where again when you talk about
rural communities a lot of micro and
small businesses across rural
communities that is something that
directly assists them so does the
actions that we take on child poverty
and you know when you actually look at
the facts child poverty across the UK is
27 and Wales it's 34 in England 29 in
Northern Ireland 24 and in Scotland 21
now the institute for fiscal studies uh
have said amongst the poorest 30 of
households incomes are boosted by around
and two thousand pounds per year
compared to England and Wales in
Scotland
there are transformational policies to
help people the policy of free bus
passes uh bus travel for young people in
every part of Scotland the expansion of
free high quality child care to 1140
hours available for three and
four-year-olds and two-year-olds from
low-income households the best start
Foods Grant Hill the cost of buying
healthy food for families with young
children three Best Start Grants for
pivotal that could be pivotal in child's
lives and for low-income families 600
pounds for the first child 300 pounds
for the birth of a later child the
Scottish child payment the baby box the
free child care extension free School
meals free free bus passes and much more
from the Scottish government to help out
I will give away
The Honorable gentlemen agree with me
that the problem with 13 years of
austerity is austerity may make the
treasury balance sheet look good in the
first year but what it does is starves
local economies because people have no
money to spend and therefore we see
boarded up high streets and in the end
that reduces the tax state to
governments and therefore it simply
doesn't work
my honorable friend is exactly right
when she says it starves communities
worse than that it starves families it
starves children it starves all with all
of the opportunity that we can have for
people because we don't have those
advantages that we should have if we had
the powers at our disposal in order to
make the kinds of decisions that we need
to make now these these uh supports they
said no I'm going to finish on just a
second these supports that I've uh laid
out just now are the kinds of policies
that we make in Scotland to try to help
to try to mitigate I didn't talked about
that you know the the trying to mitigate
the the bedroom tax for example and
other things like that those are the
kinds of things we know I'm going to
finish in just a second these are the
kinds of things that we try to do in
Scotland to help to mitigate the harms
from this place we could do so much more
we could do things very very differently
to this place but we need the powers of
Independence in order to do it
[Applause]
and we're moving on to the wind ups and
the I'm anticipating divisions in 20
minutes time Davey Linden
yeah yeah thank you very much Mr David
speaking it's our pleasure to close this
debate on behalf of the Scottish
national party today I want to start by
thanking my honorable friend the member
for Paisley and Memphitz South who
opened the debate and Lead BR
scale of the cost of living crisis for
people all across these islands
um it's been remarked on over the course
of the debates that there have been a
number of contributions mainly it's got
to be said from the SNP benches uh
however and I do want to single out that
the one conservative party contribution
from The Honorable gentleman the member
for Murray he started off in expressing
uh almost a degree of frustration that
the motion before the house uh today
touched on the big issues and then spent
the rest of his speech complaining of
other issues that he wished he could
debate most of which were under the
competence of the Scottish Parliament
which of course he is a member of
um but it was nonetheless very good of
him to Grace himself with his presence
and we did have a contribution from
mountable friend the member from
Midlothian he spoke eloquently about the
challenge to businesses in Midlothian as
a result of the cost of living crisis
and was followed by my honorable friend
the member for Angus who very expertly
reverted many of the points from The
Honorable member from Murray about
comparisons with education policy in
England modern friend the member for
Edinburgh North and leaf spoke about
food and drink The Honorable gentleman
the member of Farkle coding could be um
he spoke about the impact of the isadena
energy costs in kirkcaldy friend the
member for Glasgow north
um was right to open a speech by
painting a picture most of us at first
thought he was talking about brexit but
actually it was a reminder of all of the
scale stories that we were told in the
run-up to the referendum in 2014 every
single one of which have come to pass
while Scotland remains a member of the
United Kingdom and he was right to do so
normal area member foreign
she almost avoided mentioning any
mention of brexit they've gone from
being the party of people's votes to the
party of don't mention brexit what she's
about to do now
hopefully point out that perhaps The
Honorable member wasn't in the chamber
or didn't hear when I talked about
brexit because my party is more than
happy to point out the damage that it's
doing to the economy as I did and I
spoke so perhaps you would like to go
back and check the record
but I think one of the points was that
the honorable lady she talks an awful
lot about brexit and the damage of
brexit the reality is her party was
advocating people's vote knowing the
fact that brexit was a disaster so I
would ask her if she would just reflect
on the hypocrisy of liberal Democrats
and this idea that when the facts change
people should have the opportunity to
change their minds but sort of again
that happened
I think I'm ready to say that not only
did the liberal Democrats
um propose a people's vote they propose
that if they formed the government of
the United Kingdom after the last
general election they would have
reversed brexit immediately so they
actually see that you can have a de
facto referendum in the shape of a
general election because that was their
policy to undo brexit if they won the UK
general election they of course were
happy to continue with brexit yeah yeah
I would just caution model within the
member for Glasgow North not to take
absolutely seriously any of the
commitments made the liberal Democrats
general election and I know that the
labor party have been taking a leaf out
of the book or from that click when it
comes to the issue of tuition fees and
run up to general election but perhaps
don't believe you have that and I'm
actually flip and modern friend remember
for our phone spoke about energy and
indeed modern within the member for
Paisley and run for sure North it's both
passionate about businesses and his
constituency and the Very impact that
brexit is having upon them I was my
little heart was was cheered the wave
and the unbelieving the member for
Leicester East got to feet to take part
in the debate it was only about five
minutes into the speech that I realized
that she's not a member of the labor
party anymore so therefore we couldn't
tack them off our speech and then we
were finished off by my honorable friend
the member for
invernessby who spoke about a number of
issues namely fuel poverty in the
highlands which has been a massive issue
probably not there is a common theme
this afternoon especially from
colleagues on the SNP benches and I know
it's born out from what we're all Mr
Deputy speaker feeding on the doorsteps
and in short that theme which came up
time and again is that Scotland can no
longer afford to be tied to an
intransigent British government which is
plowing on with brexit at any cost and
it is clearer than ever that we need
Independence so that people in Scotland
can stop paying the price for disastrous
decisions made here in London by a
government that Scotland did not vote
for indeed we have not voted for the
Tories since
1955. but we should be clear that the
cost of living crisis is not necessarily
a new thing yes it's got worse but for
many of those those that I represent in
glasgow's East End the cost of living
crisis has been a permanent fixture in
the leads due to westminster's inability
to truly tackle structural inequality
and in short the cost of living crisis
is the culmination of 13 long brutal
cold years of austerity policies
compounded by brexit in last year's Khan
Academy budget which crashed their
economy and trashed the Tories record on
economic credibility but let us just
looked at the backdrop against which
today's debate takes place because in
this the SEC Rochester economy in the
world baby formula is now security
tagged it's now put behind tools so that
mothers stealing milk to feed their
children now if that is the image that
ministers wish to project when it comes
to Global Britain then it's certainly a
look I'll give them that but I think it
would be remiss of me when we focus on
supermarkets and retailers and how we
discuss the cost of living crisis to
look at what's before the motion today
and I would ask members to think very
carefully about what is in the motion
because it deals with the issue of price
gouging none of which was referenced by
the front benches and leads for tougher
action in what has been dubbed greed
inflation now we believe that ministers
should follow the leads of other
European countries to bring down the
price of foods and other necessities a
view which is supported by many of my
constituents who are absolutely baffled
whilst Westminster stands idly by whilst
food prices continue to Skyrocket
for example France introduced a price
block on Staple products with
supermarkets pledging to keep the prices
of certain foods and hygiene products as
low as possible and it's precisely Mr
various because for that reason that the
British government must intervene and
put pressure on major retailers to pass
on falling wholesale prices to Consumers
but more than that it's vital that the
competition and markets Authority
utilize the full powers that they have
here and impose maximum fines where
evidence of police coaching has found
because profiteering from selling basic
necessities is unjust at any time but at
a time when numbers and that record
numbers of people are turning to food
banks and skipping news is simply
important
but the bank of England recently found
the following costs at some companies we
are not automatically being passed
through to Consumer prices in an attempt
to rebuild profit margins
indeed's Master David speaking it was
just revealed on Friday that the chief
executive of Tesco received a 4.4
million pound pay packet last year
Ken Murphy was given a base salary of
1.37 billion pounds and received 2.73
million in an annual bonus making around
197 times the amount of the average
Tesco worker that is the level of
inequality that we have baked into a
system which is broken and broken Beyond
repair and I can tell you that when I go
to Tesco in chat Austin the very many
people that are bump into they are are
shocked at the idea that you have a boss
pointing and 4.4 million pounds when
many of them are trying to work out what
they can remove from their basket so
they're looking enough to get by
of course stubbornly High inflation
extends so much more than food each week
on the doorsteps can statements tell me
of how they've resorted to rationing
baths and showers simply to save when
energy costs
and that my constituents live in an
energy reactionation but experience High
watering levels of fuel poverty is a
damning indictment of just how
ridiculous the situation has become and
why change is desperately needed but we
know that all of this is exacerbated by
brexit a brexit which Scotland projected
it has had voiced it upon us
indeed it is the only nation in these
islands to have been sold royally
screwed over as a result of the 2016
referendum but we all know from better
experience that the slogans on the side
of buses were nothing more than empty
rhetoric in 2016 the right Noble member
for North East Somerset slammed the
resolution foundation's findings that
food prices would increase as a result
of brexit as ridiculous claiming that
the price of food will go down after
brexit what's more last year as he
suggested that the rules that the
British government follows whilst being
part of the EU made and I quote life
harder for small businesses and
increased the costs of operating that Mr
Deputy speaker is an entirely false
claim the hard brexit The Minister's
pursued has made life harder for food
exporting and importing businesses and
don't just take my word for it Nick
Allen chief executive of the British
Processors Association told the
independent that the extra burden of new
paperwork and fees will see some small
specialist importers struggling to
survive and we know the price of brexit
and it is one that Scotland cannot
afford to pay
now the opr predicted in March that the
UK's GDP will fall four percent as a
result of brexit with trade-in exports
reducing some 15 percent
and we simply released figures by the
onx show that the UK economy contracted
0.3 in March making the UK the worst
performing economy out of the G7 the
only G7 economy to experience negative
economic growth and on Thursday last
week the bank of England Rose interest
rates to 4.5 the 12th consecutive
interest rate rise
and for many of our constituents coming
off of affect Street they are literally
watching hundreds of pounds being added
to the mortgage bill as a Tory premium
simply for the pleasure of having an
incompetent Westminster government that
Scotland did not look for the
conservative party inflecting economic
pain is hardly a surprise to my
constituents it's probably why we've not
had a conservative MP in East End for
over 110 years but what of the labor
party offed to my right and I mean that
in more respects than one because in
this labor party we have nothing more
than a pound shop Tony Blair tribute act
which is devoid of ideas and watching
ever further to the right in a desperate
Scramble for the votes of Tori English
Market towns and on the biggest issues
of the day which have caused economic
harm to these islands the labor party
has I'm afraid nothing to see on
immigration policy more of the same on
brexit more of the same on Social
Security more of the same and so I
therefore see to our calling from
Edinburgh South and labor benches simply
hoping that the Tories just run out of
steam and that the keys to number 10
Downing Street land into the laps of
starmer and streeting is no vision to
infuse electors because in my
constituency voters are clear they want
brexit they want their MP showing
solidarity with public sector workers
striking for therapy you want a social
security system that provides a safety
net and yes unashamedly they want an
immigration system that is not driven by
focus groups and dog whistle politics
but is responsive to the needs of our
small island nation and its economic
needs these Master Deputy speaker are
the challenges that Scotland faces today
but by feeling the support today's
motion on the biggest issue of the day
labor and the Tories are simply showing
Scotland that it stands at a fork in the
roads and the choice could not be
clearer Scotland can Veer off to the
right with the full factories or the
directories in pursue yet more economic
self-harm with brexit and austerity
where it can Veer left by voting yes to
Independence rejoining the European
Union and unhooking itself from the bin
fire the economic bin fire that is the
United Kingdom and it's on that basis
that commend the motion to the house
um well we had um agreed 10 minute
wind-ups and there seems to have been 40
inflation on that
so
I wasn't going to stop stop you because
it is your debate but I have to give
equal time so minister
[Applause]
Mr Deputy speaker I should say
you've changed so much during the day
speaker I I think as parliamentarians we
must first and foremost be Democrats and
in respect of the decision of the
British people on the EU referendum we
must be accepting of that Democratic
decision
I believe also in respect of the
decision of the Scottish people in
respect of the Scottish referendum that
we must accept that decision I wish that
the party opposite did accept that
decision
I was proud as the Member of Parliament
for hexam which goes to Carter bar on
the border to campaign from Aberdeen to
Allen from the borders to Edinburgh to
make the case for the union and I
believe we should continue to do so in
this place
[Music]
it is unquestionably the case Mr Deputy
speaker that this government fully
appreciates and is assessing and
assisting the pressures that households
face across the United Kingdom
it is quite clear this is derived by
reason of the challenges of high
inflation the impacts of covid and the
impacts of global issues most
particularly the Putin invasion in
Ukraine
that is why we continue to take
extensive action to help households in
23 24 we have increased benefit rates
and state pensions by 10.1 percent and
will spend around 276 billion pounds
through welfare support in Great Britain
we have never spent more in this country
on low-income families the disabled or
pensioners
in respect to the cost of living the
steps we have taken over the last year
show that this is a government that will
always protect those who are most
vulnerable the total support package we
have provided uh to help with the rising
bills is worth over 94 billion pounds
across 2023 and 2024 20 23 24. that's
over 3 300 pounds per UK household on
average including this are the cost of
living payments made to over 8 million
low-income households around 6 million
disabled people and over 8 million
pensioner households last year and
pension credit has had a massive
increase in implications of a hundred
and seventy percent the government paid
out 37 billion pounds in the summer of
2022 billions in Autumn 2022 and the DWP
has recently made cost of living
payments worth 2.2 billion pounds so far
this year
this year over 8 million households will
get additional payments of up to 900
pounds over 99 of eligible households on
a DWP means tested benefit have now
received their first cost of living
payment during 2023-24 of 301 pounds and
we see that over 6 million people across
the UK on eligible disability benefits
will receive a further 150 pound
disability cost of living payment this
summer to help with additional costs a
more than 8 million households of
pensioners across the UK will receive an
additional 300 pound cost of living
payments this winter and we also have
included on an ongoing support the cost
of living support of the energy price
guarantee which continues to the summer
clearly we believe very strongly that
work is the best way out of poverty the
we have the opportunity through our job
centers up and down the country to
assist people and to provide support for
them all across the country whether that
is young people through youth hubs
whether that is the 50 Plus offer
whether that is the in-work progression
whether it is the massive increase in
disability employment
we are progressing those and supporting
those people who are in work to get
better jobs and a better opportunity for
the way ahead that's why we're extending
the support our job centers offer to
low-paid workers so they can increase
their hours and move into better paid
higher quality jobs for those on a
Universal Credit
we are increasing the child care maximum
cap to 951 pounds for one child and
sixteen hundred and thirty pounds for
two or more children
we are paying child care costs up front
when parents parents move into paid work
or increase their hours
and we are further supporting working
people with the largest ever increase to
the National living wage that's an
increase of 9.7 percent to 10 pounds 42
an hour from this April this represents
an increase of over 1600 pounds to the
annual earnings of a full-time worker
there was much criticism uh Mr Deputy
speaker of the UK economy but we have to
bear in mind that the UK has the fourth
highest employment rate in the G7 that
is higher than the US it's higher than
France it's higher than Italy
we have unemployment rates that remains
low at 3.9 percent we have more people
on the payroll employment than before
the pandemic at 30 million
there's a substantial package part of
which I've outlined of Labor Market
interventions announced at the spring
budget which are a huge boost to our
efforts we see youth unemployment so you
as as The Honorable gentleman's
colleague said probably not
um we have youth employment which is
second best in the G7
uh we have economic inactivity back at
2018 levels and we have vacancies that
have dropped 10 quarters in a row
the
reality of the situation is that we
heard much from the SMP uh during the
debate no talk whatsoever of uh luxury
Camper vans worth a hundred thousand
pounds no talk of missing Auditors no
talk of ferries to The Western Isles
that don't exist presumably those
ferries have both the Auditors and the
campervans on them no talk of the child
Commissioners uh comments that the SMP
Scottish government had failed its
people no talk of the 16 years of
failure on police on education on health
no talk of their abandonment total
abandonment of the oil and gas sector
yeah and we're having a discussion Mr
Deputy speaker a discussion on the cost
of living and they would rather import
uh oil and gas from overseas than
actually support the hundred thousand
jobs in the northeast of Scotland with
the support the businesses that we have
and the truth is they are in partnership
with the greens who are closely related
to Extinction Rebellion who are clearly
an explicitly stated that they are
anti-economic growth
why would we import when we can address
cost of living with something that is
homegrown and support over a hundred
thousand jobs in the northeast of
Scotland that is what this government is
doing that is what my honorable friend
from Murray is doing and we should
support him wholeheartedly in this
process we have just passed the
Shakespeare's anniversary of 400 years
of publication of the uh Macbeth a tale
interestingly Mr Deputy speaker of a
husband and wife in Scotland whose
misdemeanors finally catch up with them
I I I'm absolutely sure there is no
reference to the present day whatsoever
I'm absolutely sure that the discussion
of Independence is always tomorrow
tomorrow tomorrow that they're
absolutely sure that there is nobody
here who is full of Sound and Fury
signifying nothing but I am absolutely
certain that this government is
assisting on an ongoing basis and I
strongly commend the prime minister of
motion to the house
hey